Yes.
Genuine,
genuinely giving her
perspective or just arguing?
Well,
that's a good question.
Let's see if we can,
let's see if we can formulate that.
So
the first difference might be,
well,
what's,
what's the outcome we're looking for?
Like let's,
let's think about that.
Let's think about that in the context of,
uh,
of an intimate relationship,
a familial relationships.
So you have a wife,
let's say,
and you've got some kids just wonder,
what are you up,
dude?
What do you want?
Hopefully.
Okay.
So that's one thing we're,
so that we're trying to
establish the domain of the year.
We're going to,
we're going to try to make things better.
What would better look like?
You think
you could try a little bit my name,
whatever negative emotion I can feel like.
Okay,
so,
so there's something,
okay.
So that's a rough area of presupposition.
Is that part of what you're doing
when you're making things better is to
decrease the probability that negative
emotion will arise short term or long
term?
Short term.
First.
That's what bothering me.
Ah,
okay.
So that's an interesting thing because
what if you have to experience a
tremendous amount of short term pain
in order to make long term progress?
If it's different from the pain that
initially got me thinking about it seems
like an improvement potentially.
Okay.
Well
I'm going to address your question
completely from a ps Yeti and perspective,
but that's okay because it
works for Rogers as well.
It's just easier to explain
freedom from unnecessary suffering
in the short,
medium,
and long term across as many
people as you can imagine manage.
So we'll say,
let's start with you and your family.
Okay,
how are you going to do that?
You don't know.
That's what you have to talk about.
Okay.
But you cannot have that conversation
until you've got that framework.
Right.
So it's very,
very tricky because in
the midst of the argument,
there's going to be tremendous temptation
to oppress and deceive and humiliate
and,
and treat with contempt and hurt and
punish and threatened all of those things.
Right?
And that that's partly reactivity
in the short term and then it's not,
that's not properly integrated into
the overarching hierarchical structure.
So you've got to keep bringing
yourself back to that.
It's like,
why should you control your impulses?
Well,
because their manifestation
in the present,
they're spontaneous and impulsive
manifestation in the present.
Well,
although that may be,
it may carry with it a
feeling of freedom and power,
maybe destroying the very structured
that's going to provide you with peace and
stability over the medium and long run.
So it's again,
it's the idea of contradiction.
Now,
if we're having a discussion,
okay,
so let's say,
well,
we'll do this in a very local fashion.
It's like,
okay,
well let's say you're having a discussion
about with your partner about who's
going to cook dinner.
Okay.
You think that's a simple discussion.
It's like it's not a simple discussion.
It's a horrible discussion.
It's where the war between
the genders manifests itself.
It's one of the places.
And to solve it,
did he not?
You actually have to solve
the war between the genders.
Well,
good luck with doc and there
it is right in your house.
Right?
It's like a snake in the garden.
There's no getting rid of it.
Okay.
So then you might think,
well,
what's our aim for dinner?
Well,
do we want to have wretched,
miserable,
rotten foods served by a resentful
person to a bunch of ungrateful rats who
complained and sniffle?
It's like,
no,
let's assume we don't want,
we don't want that.
Okay,
good.
Well we've got,
you know what we're not aiming at.
So like,
all right,
um,
who should cook dinner and when and what
are the rules by which we decide that?
Huh?
That's a tough one because
you can return to roles,
right?
That's what you,
that's why people have roles.
So they don't have to have
stupid conversations like this,
but that time is gone.
Okay.
So what do you do when there's no role?
Well,
I could make you do it.
Maybe you know,
by,
I could either do it physically by force
or I could just intimidate you or I
could make life miserable
for you if you don't do it.
Or you know,
there's lots of ways of,
of,
of using power.
Problem with that is you're not worthy.
You're not without your own book.
What happens?
And for every step I take
towards making you miserable,
you'll get your chance.
So probably we don't want to use force
plus that's not so good for the kids.
You know,
from a role model perspective
and hypothetically,
we want good things to
be happening to them.
So tyranny looks like it's out.
And I don't want you to subjugate yourself
because maybe like maybe you're very
agreeable,
let's say that because that's often a
problem in communication between men and
women.
The guys more disagreeable
then the woman is.
And so if he like Jack
Suck the level of conflict,
show back off because she doesn't like
conflict for all sorts of different
reasons.
So that's another way of winning.
Except then the person who loses his
all resentful and you end up with,
you know,
horrible,
miserable food fed two warring partners
who are complaining in and struggling.
It's not a good solution.
Right?
So then what you're left with,
well then you've gotten,
okay,
so I might say,
well,
do we agree that we need to have dinner?
Well,
you know,
when you might think,
okay,
well we could agree on that.
How often should we have it at home?
Well that's going to require
a fair bit of thought.
You want to go out now and then how often,
how much is that going to cost?
What are we going to span?
Where are we going to go?
Okay,
who pays?
so that's going to be
like a whole conversation.
So let's say we figured that out.
It's like five days a week
we're going to stay home.
Okay,
who's going to occur?
Well,
do you like cooking?
Do I like cooking?
Not something to sort out.
So that would be,
that's like a little
discussion with your own
physiology in some sense.
You know,
what's your felt state while
you're preparing the food?
And maybe he'll say,
well,
I like it.
I'll cook the,
if,
if there's someone in the
kitchen with me and uh,
you know,
someone else cleans up afterwards.
Um,
then it turns out that I
don't mind cooking while,
and then you might say,
well,
is not minding good enough or
do you really want to enjoy it?
It's like,
what's the preconditions?
What preconditions would have
to be met for you to enjoy it.
While you want to think about that,
because if you can get the person,
either of you,
who the hell cares to enjoy that,
then it's sort of self sustaining,
right?
You put that into place and then the
thing runs smoothly across multiple
iterations.
And so then you might think,
well what are the preconditions for us
to do that in a way that would be joyful
that say,
okay,
well that's a high,
that's a high bar.
It's like,
well
one or the other,
but should learn to cook because
otherwise we're going to eat and like,
you know,
canned spaghetti or some other sort of
horror and that's not very high quality.
So that problem might have to be solved.
And then there's the problem of how
you react to the person when they cook.
You know,
like do you just assume that that's
their bloody responsibility and if they
don't live up to it,
there's something wrong with them?
Or do you notice what they're doing and
express some appreciation and gratitude
and and in a way that would increase
the probability that would happen again,
that'd be a better solution.
So then you have to negotiate
about how you're going to do that.
Exactly.
Maybe even right down
to the level of words,
but what you're sir,
see what you're,
you're trying to serve a
higher order by doing that,
right?
You're trying to,
you're trying to satisfy
basic organismal needs,
the provision of food.
But I mean,
food is complicated for human
beings because we just don't,
you just don't put dog food
in the bowl and chow down.
Even dogs won't do that.
Our dog won't eat less.
We're eating,
you know,
so human beings are
extremely social leaders,
so you have to get that right and so,
but the conversation will only take
place in the proper manner if your
orientation is proper in the,
during the conversation.
And the orientation needs to be,
how can we make this better for both of
us in the long run and for the people
around us and that you have
to bow down before that.
In some sense as the highest,
highest order principle
that you're serving.
And then you can stumble
around trying to work that out.
And then you might say,
well you cook three times a week and I
cooked twice and I'll take care of it
once.
And then of course you have to get the
whole grocery thing settled out and
that's a whole other bloody
complicated conversation,
but it needs to be done.
And then you might say,
well,
let's run this for a couple of weeks and
we'll see how it goes and then we can
meet again and we can discuss
what worked and what didn't.
And the goal is to make it better,
make it better and make it
better and make it better.
And then no one's trying to win.
Well,
it depends on what you mean by
when I'm not trying to defeat you,
why we'll have to live with you.
That'd be the first reasons.
Like,
what the hell good is it defeating you?
Unless I want someone
100 around like this,
you know,
resentful and bitter.
Maybe I do want that,
but I don't think that's a
very good place to start.
So when you have a client
come in to see you,
the rule is,
I can tell you the rules I
used cause they're Rogerian.
Um,
I will tell the person what I think.
So I won't tell them that
what I think is right.
But if they're doing something and I,
I have a reaction to that of some sort
that'll usually express itself in a
fantasy or a thought.
And I'll just tell them what happened.
And you know,
I tried to do it as gently as I possibly
can because you can use the truth as a
club,
but then that's not the truth.
And then at least they get the honest
response of one person to what they're
like.
And I'll tell you,
I've seen lots of people who've never
got the honest response of any one person
ever in their whole
life to what their life.
And so they have no idea what they're
like or what's annoying other people or
how they should behave
or any of those things.
So,
even though I'm not going to be right,
and you know,
in that my reactions won't be a precisely
accurate representation of the average
response of other people,
which is basically what
you're trying to model.
It's going to be a lot better
than they've had so far.
And then now than precondition is
you're going to try really hard to get
yourself together,
whatever that means.
We're going to talk about whatever that
means and I'm going to support you in
that.
And that's our goal.
And that that's a variant of Rogerian
unconditional positive regard.
And his,
his unconditional positive
regard in some sense was,
was the setup for the therapy.
So the presupposition is your valuable,
although maybe you're a little
on the bent and twisted side,
but you know,
maybe you could be straightened up
into something that's like deadly.
And uh,
we're going to start with
that presupposition and
we're going to learn on the
way.
But that's what,
that's what we're,
that's what we're doing that,
so the unconditional positive regard,
it's like a human rights thinking because
the basis of the idea of human rights
is that people are valuable.
They have some intrinsic value,
you know,
and the,
the,
I think maybe it's PR,
it's reasonable to presuppose that from
the Reef Raj area perspective is that
what's valuable about you
as you're being right?
You're a conscious,
you're a locus of experience.
And as such,
here are unique locus of experience.
you,
you have something to contribute
that no one else can contribute.
And that that's valuable.
It's intrinsically valuable.
That's the basic presupposition
of the idea of human rights,
by the way.
So if that's acted out in
the therapeutic session,
but it's acted out in any relationship,
that's therapeutic.